(white noise)
- My name is Mark Laita,
and I produce the videos
that you see on my channel,
Soft White Underbelly.
I've been a photographer since I was 14.
And I spent most of my career
doing advertising work.
So I'm basically helping
wealthy corporations
become even wealthier.
I realized as I got
older, that was my legacy.
And I didn't feel comfortable with that.
So I wanted to do something
that mattered more in the world.
The name Soft White Underbelly
came from Winston Churchill,
who back in World War II was
advising the United States
on how best to attack Germany.
And he called Italy the
soft underbelly of Europe,
meaning that was the most
vulnerable spot that Germany had
to come in from Italy.
These videos are meant to
create awareness of things
that are broken in our country.
If we don't look at some of these things,
they're just gonna continue to grow
and get worse and worse.
And I believe listening,
understanding, accepting
and maybe deciding to
do something differently
might make a difference eventually,
and help the next
generation or two of parents
raise kids who have more hope,
have better role models, have
both parents in their lives.
That's my hope.
That's my aim with this work.
It's not to help the addict
that's outside my door,
even though I've done that.
I've done that many times.
Over the last 10 years, I've
talked with about 1,000 people
and financially I've probably
spent $150,000 helping people
with tents with, "Oh, you need shoes,
you need clothes, you need food,
you need a cell phone to
call your parole officer,
you need," all these kind of things.
Day after day after day,
every time I'm down here,
I'm bleeding money.
But that's not what this channel is about.
It has nothing to do with this channel.
This channel is purely
about what I just said,
which is helping our society,
helping our government
figure out what's wrong with our country,
and hopefully build a better system.
Like the wealth inequality
that goes on here,
the education and opportunity inequalities
create this stuff.
I mean, I talked to some of these kids,
or some of these people, and
said, "When they were kids,
they had no hope of a bright future.
There was no chance of it."
So that's what I think needs to change.
I've helped some addicts.
That's a personal thing I do.
It has nothing to do with this channel.
I'm just showing you some
things that are wrong
with the country.
Sometimes that's just
too much to deal with.
It's just too much to look at.
And I'll watch these videos
or listen to these talks,
listen to these people, and I'll do it
on a more personal level,
a more like individual,
like I see self destructive
or self sabotaging behavior
in myself, and I'll be
able to apply the story
that I'm hearing, maybe not as extreme.
Some of these stories
are really horrifying,
and my childhood was nothing like these.
But the mechanics are still the same.
You know, the stuff that happens to you
as a kid ends up affecting
the way you believe
in yourself, which ends
up manifesting as problems
with alcohol, or drugs, or your diet,
or taking care of your health,
or your choice of partners,
or your career choices,
or your belief in yourself
and the education that you decide to get.
And there's so many things that
we're our own worst enemies
sometimes, and I think that's
an interesting story as well.
And if you watch these
videos, you'll be like,
"Wow, that's what was going on with them.
That's why they're doing
what they're doing."
And then you can kind of
apply it to your own life,
at least I can.
Other times I just find
listening to all these talks
like a crash course in empathy.
I used to look at homeless people and go,
"Man why don't they just get a job?
Quit the drug, get a job. Problem solved."
Now, after hearing all these stories,
I realize what these people have gone
through in their childhoods,
how they're broken,
how they never had a chance.
They never had hope.
And it's built my compassion
and empathy for these people,
like nothing else.
And then other times I can't
handle any of the above.
And I just watch these videos
as like interesting character studies.
I get to listen to people
that I would never,
ever meet in my life.
And they're interesting and fascinating,
and I leave it at that.
That's all I can bite off for the day.
So if you have the strength
and courage to watch
these videos, that's great.
And if you don't, I understand.
They're not for everybody.
But if we're gonna change our country,
we're gonna need to
understand why it's broken,
what's wrong with it.
And here's a really good window
into what's really going on.
I hope you enjoy my work,
and thank you for watching.
Oh, and by the way, there's
a handful or more videos
that had been deleted from my
channel for various reasons.
And starting tomorrow,
I'll start uploading
those videos again.
They're just slightly changed
to protect the subject
or for some reason just to meet YouTube's
community guidelines or whatever it takes
so that they don't get deleted.
And you'll start seeing those tomorrow.
They're some of the best videos I've done,
and I just thought it was a
shame that they don't exist
on my channel.
So you'll start seeing those tomorrow,
and thank you for watching
(white noise)